So, ich bin nochmal am Start, auch wenn es recht spät ist, muss mal wieder sein, wobei, was heißt mal wieder, gestern habe ich auch schon gestreamt, davor auch, letzten Tag, was heißt mal mal wieder, letzten Tage war doch sogar eigentlich relativ viel.
Wir haben übrigens bald wieder Bastel-Stream, morgen, wenn wir Glück haben, mitgebastelt und zwar, ich habe mir ja sowas gekauft, ich habe mir, ich habe mir vernetzt, also funkvernetzbare Rauchmelder gekauft, Leute, ich muss mal kurz das Headset entwirren, ganz kurz, so, ich glaube, so ist besser, was ist das eigentlich für ein Knopf hier, ah, ne, da hat man nichts mehr, weiß, super Knopf, also ich habe mir ja funkvernetzbare Rauchmelder gekauft und ich habe mir so eine, also das ist, das sind so,
das sind funkvernetzbare Rauchmelder und so eine Steuerung vom Hersteller, die eigentlich gedacht ist, an die, also so eine Warnanlage anzuschließen, aber die haben drei Output-Relays und eines der Output-Relays ist eben, schaltet eben, wenn einer der Feuermelder anschlägt und das ist kaputt, was ich mir gekauft habe, das heißt, morgen kommt das nächste und das probieren wir dann gleich mal zusammen aus, ob ich einfach nur zu blöd war, das zu bedienen oder ob das alte wirklich kaputt war,
war das, das blöd, ne, bei blöd.
So, jetzt müssen wir da, glaube ich, gar nicht so viel, ich habe den Stecker ja schon dran, den kann ich vom alten nehmen, das gucken wir uns dann morgen mal an.
Pog, Pogge, Pogge, Poggie, Poggie, nicht Puggie, Puggie, ja, moin Leute, schon ist das neueste FireShip-Video, das Leute, Sekunde, Sekunde, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, so, ich glaube, so ist besser, so, exzellent.
Nein, das neueste FireShip-Video.
Das neue FireShip-Video habe ich noch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe es aufgemacht, das gucken wir uns gleich zusammen an.
Levels passen.
Hast du Urlaub oder warum so oft?
Nein, ich bin wieder etwas halbwegs gesund, nachdem ich mich jetzt vier oder fünf Wochen oder was das war, mit Entzündung im Hals rumgeschlagen habe.
Ein Nachteil hat das mit Entzündung im Hals, ich habe jetzt so Pillen, die dafür sorgen, dass es besser heilt, aber gleichzeitig sorgen die dafür, dass mein Immunsystem nicht so,
so,
so fit ist, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt rausgehe und Corona kriege, dann sterbe ich wahrscheinlich, nein, das ist übertrieben, wahrscheinlich sterbe ich nicht, aber ich werde wahrscheinlich, also die, die Chance, die Chance, richtig krank zu werden, ist auf jeden Fall deutlich höher jetzt, nachdem ich diese Pillen genommen habe, gegen meine Entzündung im Hals und deswegen bin ich da überhaupt kein Fan von, nach Frankfurt zu fahren.
Breese, Breese rief, ja, schön, dass du auch da bist, aber heute war ja kein Zwölf.
Lofos 1,
10 Monate,
Dankeschön für die Hyper-Subscriptions hier.
Aber nee, ich habe keinen Urlaub.
Urlaub habe ich erst wieder richtig lang im Dezember.
Und das sind ja noch, leider, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Monate.
Oder je nachdem, wie man es, ne, 10 Monate kann nicht sein.
Ich habe mich verzählt.
Ergibt da eigentlich auch keinen Sinn, es sind 9 Monate, eigentlich sind es nur noch 8 Monate bis Dezember.
Eigentlich ist es nur noch 8 Monate bis Dezember.
Eigentlich sind es ja nur noch 8 Monate, weil ich habe ja immer quasi schon letzte Novemberwoche auch Urlaub.
Eigentlich muss ich nur noch 8 Monate durchhalten, dann habe ich wieder einen Monat Urlaub.
Ja, die Entzündung im Hals war nicht wegen Gachi-Bass.
Du hast gerade mein Video geschaut.
Nice.
Du meinst das Homeoffice-Video, das da.
Das da.
Übrigens, dieses Emoji, wer sich gefragt hat, was hat, was hat dieses Emoji damit zu tun?
Nichts.
Aber dieses Emoji ist neu im letzten Unicode-Standard und ist jetzt auf den meisten Betriebssystemen verfügbar.
Microsoft ist da nicht so schnell.
Und ich dachte mir, hier ist ein Bild vom Strand, warum machen wir nicht einfach so einen Melting-Emoji rein?
Ich hätte auch Monat S reinmachen können.
Das ist gut.
Das schauen wir uns gleich an.
Das Problem ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Mir ist egal, ob ich nach Frankfurt fahren muss oder nicht.
Das Problem ist mit der Bahn fahren.
Also, wie gesagt, jetzt habe ich falsch gesagt.
Es ist egal, ob ich die Bahn jetzt nach Frankfurt fahren müsste oder in irgendeine x-beliebliche andere Stadt.
Das Problem ist Bahn fahren.
Und das ist absolute Zumutung.
Es ist einfach, es ist einfach nicht eines Landes angemessen, was das viertgrößte...
Wo haben wir denn jetzt das Bahn-Emote?
Ja, das ist einfach nicht angemessen für ein Land, das die viertgrößte Industrienation der Welt ist.
Ich meine, vor uns sind nur die China-Chinesen, die USA und Japan.
Ich glaube, es war Japan, wenn ich nicht ganz durcheinander geraten bin.
Die mehr Stonks machen als wir.
Und dafür ist unsere Infrastruktur ziemlich beschissen.
Stream mal Montag.
Ja.
Ja, warum nicht?
Poor Girls.
Äh, warum war nicht mal wieder Battlefield 3 auf Ehre?
Auf Ehre, ja.
Weiß ich nicht, wann ich auf Ehre Battlefield 3 spiele wieder.
Auf, auf meinen Nacken, Alter.
Ich habe eine Weile Battlefield 3 nicht mehr angeschmissen.
Aber es bleibt ja aktuell gar nichts anderes übrig.
Battlefield 2042 sackt.
Mega, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Sekunde.
Die Sache, die ich in jedem Stream am Anfang...
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Cyberpunk.
Die Sache, die ich in jedem Stream am Anfang machen muss, ist, eine Runde kecken.
Über die Spielerzahlen von Battlefield.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie viel Battlefield 3 spielen.
Das sind aber wenige.
Das sind ziemlich wenige auf Steam.
Ja, 230, ne?
Aber, passt mal auf, Battlefield 4 spielen teilweise mehr.
Und das nur über Steam, obwohl es Jahre nicht auf Steam verfügbar war.
Also spielen fast mehr, 24-Hour-Peak, also spielen mehr Leute Battlefield 4 als Battlefield 2042.
Und das muss man sich immer auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Also auf Steam, auf Steam, ja.
Und das, obwohl es irgendwie erst fünf Jahre später oder so auf Steam gekommen ist.
Ja, doch, mittlerweile gibt es den Krempel auf Steam.
Aber das startet, glaube ich, im Endeffekt einfach nur Origins.
Das ist also ziemlich useless.
Fortnite hat endlich den Boomer-Mode eingeführt.
Das habe ich gehört.
Das gibt jetzt eine...
Eine Season in Fortnite ohne Bilder.
Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, weil ist nicht Bauen eigentlich so eines der Haupt-Gameplay-Mechanics von Fortnite?
Weiß jemand, wie das in der Fortnite-Community ankommt?
Ist das...
Wird das eher gehatet oder eher gefeiert, dass das Bauen rausfliegt für die Season?
Ich bin, wie sagt man so, im Fortnite-Game bin ich überhaupt nicht drin.
Es ist schön, wenn Ihnen das gefällt.
Ja, Teilzeit, Beste.
Ab wann, ab wann ist bei dir soweit?
Ab wann geht's los?
Mein Plugin zum Anzeigen funktioniert nicht mehr.
Und seitdem ich das letzte Mal fast Monkatoske-G-Baited wurde...
Ach, das habe ich gesehen, das fand ich nicht gut.
Ab 1.6.
Ja, du hast, du hast es ja fast geschafft, ne?
März ist ja quasi vorbei, also musst du im Prinzip nur noch...
Wer hat sich bei Microsoft eigentlich gedacht, dass der Pfeil nach oben einen Monat nach hinten geht?
Warum geht der Pfeil nach oben nicht einen Monat?
Nach vorne.
Welche...
Ich meine, ich meine, welches Monat-es Gehirn war Microsoft, hat sich das ausgedacht?
Das ist einfach nur maximal irritierend.
Monat nach oben sollte nicht zurückgehen, sondern nach vorne.
Und dann einfach in die umgekehrte Richtung sliden lassen und alles ist gut.
Also musst du ja im Prinzip...
Musst du ja eigentlich nur noch April und Mai überleben, dann hast du Teilzeit.
Ähm...
Auf was hast du gewechselt?
Auch vier Tage oder noch weniger?
Pfeile links und rechts wären by the way auch ziemlich gut für vor und zurück, anstatt hoch und runter.
Weil vor und zurück ist man mit Pfeilen links und rechts, kommt man damit eher klar.
Echt, ich nicht.
Aber hoch, hoch für Monat runter ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Was?
Ach so, weil man so einen kompletten Kalender hat.
Ja, aber da musst du kein Icon zum Scrollen drücken.
Subway, Pog, Subway, beste.
So.
Guck mal hier.
Ne, das ist nicht das neueste Fireship-Video.
Das ist das neueste Fireship-Video, ne?
Ja, das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ich hab gesehen, dass das hier empfohlen wird.
Gucken wir uns das gleich zusammen an.
Subway, P-Prophet.
Ich war legit bestimmt die letzten vier Jahre oder länger nicht mehr beim Subway.
Ne, Level Capture Baden gibt's heute nix, haben wir schon geguckt.
Ich war nicht mal beim Subway, und ich geh auch nicht mal zum Subway, weil...
Also, was ich ja immer übelst gerne gegessen habe, ist Subway Steak and Cheese.
Haben die das umbenannt?
Chili, Beef and Cheese?
Ist das nicht immer Steak and Cheese früher?
Ah ne, hier gibt's noch Steak and Cheese.
Ja, das da, genau.
Das da.
Das hab ich übelst gerne gegessen früher.
Aber, ich war zweimal bei einem Subway bei uns.
In Frankfurt, in der Mittagspause.
Und ich hatte danach so krass die Scheißerei.
Aber das muss nicht unbedingt jetzt an Subway allgemein liegen, sondern an dem Subway.
Und seitdem bin ich nie wieder zum Subway gegangen.
Wobei es nicht so schlimm war, wie als ich mal bei einem Lieferservice bestellt hab, hier bei mir.
In Hanau.
Hab ich bei einem Lieferservice bestellt.
Und ich hatte wirklich...
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie mir geschieht.
Ich wusste nicht, wie mir geschieht.
Ähm, ich hatte zum ersten Mal eine Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Und ich sag euch, ich war fünf Tage, oder fünf, sechs Tage, fast eine ganze Woche am Stück, einfach nur im Arsch.
Ja, im Klo war ich auch.
Aber ich war einfach eine komplette Woche im Arsch mit der Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Und das war so krass, ich hab sogar eine Nachricht vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen,
dass ich eine meldepflichtige Krankheit habe, nachdem ich beim Arzt war.
Wusste ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht.
Und es ist nicht Corona.
Alter.
Hört mal auf.
Rap, rap, bro.
Hä, naja, ich hab's ausgefüllt.
Doch, doch, ich hab's ausgefüllt.
Ich hab vor allem ausgefüllt, dass sie den Lieferservice macht.
Da hast du schon mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Ähm, echt?
Ja, kann sein.
Ich hab auch ein Video drüber gemacht, wo ich im Zug fast mal in Gang gekackt hab.
So, aber genug jetzt, genug jetzt der, äh, merkwürdigen Storys hier.
Was war's am Ende? Nein, nein, nein, es waren nicht Salmonellen, es waren...
Ich hab's euch mal erzählt, ich hab's vergessen.
Ähm...
Bacta?
Äh...
Darm?
Gibt's den da?
Campylobacter.
Ich glaub...
Ich...
Ich glaub, das ist es.
Ich glaub, das hatte ich.
Ich...
Ich glaube, das war das.
Ja.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich mir durch das Rahmenschnitzel vom Lieferservice das Ganze zugezogen hab.
Durchfallerkrankung.
Aber wie, Leute?
Ich sag's euch.
Das hat...
Das hat geflutscht.
Ja, das kann im Zweifelsfall tödlich sein.
Deswegen ist es meldepflichtig.
Guck mal, ich meine, es steht nicht umsonst nur zwei über Ebola.
Hahaha.
Hey, nur zwei Punkte über Ebola.
Also, noch mal kurz dran vorbeigeschrammt, ja.
Hahaha.
Ich meine, nicht, dass die Reihenfolge hier alphabetisch wäre oder so.
Steht da eigentlich Corona auch drin?
Wie, warum steht da Corona nicht drin?
Da steht SARS bestimmt drin oder sowas.
Nee, auch nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest das hatte ich und das war wirklich eklig.
Und ich hab...
Ich hatte noch nie das Gefühl, ich kannte das Gefühl gar nicht, dass wenn man im Bett liegt
und aufstehen will, man automatisch wieder zurück ins Bett, äh, gezogen wird.
Das ist ganz, ganz komisch.
Ich hatte auch 40 Fieber und so.
Also, das war echt, das war echt nicht spaßig.
Und seitdem habe ich auch nie wieder bei diesem Lieferdienst was bestellt und werde ich auch
nie wieder machen.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es da dran gelegen hat.
Es kommen nur zwei Lieferdienste in Frage, denen ich den Scheiß hier zu ver...
Scheiße, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Den ich, den ich, den ich, ähm, in die Frage komme.
Das ist einmal mein Dönermann um die Ecke, aber da habe ich schon sehr oft bestellt und
nie Probleme gehabt.
Außerdem passt das zeitlich auch nicht so ganz.
Oder der Lieferservice, wo ich mir Rahmschnitzel bestellt habe.
Da habe ich noch nicht so oft bestellt und Rahmschnitzel ist ja, bietet sich ja gerade an, so
ein Müll zu übertragen.
Es ist...
Es war nicht schön, ja.
So viel, so viel kann ich sagen.
Es war echt nicht schön.
Dieses Emote, okay.
Was ist das?
Chainlord, zeig her.
Zulull.
Es gibt ein neues Zulull-Emote.
Wahnsinn.
Haben wir noch das klassische Zulull oder ist das weg?
Wir haben kein Zulull mehr.
Okay, Chainlord, weil du es bist, es gibt jetzt ein neues Zulull.
Add to Channel hat nicht funktioniert.
Warum nicht?
Chainlord, ich kann nichts adden.
Es ist kaputt.
Bei der Twitch-TV.
Oh, ich habe 100 Emotes.
Voll.
Bei Better Twitch-TV.
Leute, wir müssen mal, wir müssen mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen was aussortieren.
Ich habe noch das Original-Zulull drin.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Das ist anscheinend broken, oder?
Ist das banned?
Okay, dann mache ich das Zulull raus und dein Zulull rein.
Alles klar.
Bam.
Passt.
Ist drin.
Banned.
Warum ist Zulull banned?
Hä?
Okay, muss ich nicht verstehen.
Hast du dir mal angesehen?
Files.
Community.
Ich mache so Seiten nicht im Stream auf.
Ach so.
Das ist irgendein File Explorer oder sowas.
Das ist Modern File Explorer that pushes boundaries of the platform.
Okay.
Das ist quasi Windows Explorer nur in gut oder wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Warum sind da Symbole von Mega gerade drin gewesen?
Habt ihr das auch gesehen?
Da war gerade Google Drive und Mega irgendwie.
Okay.
Mega.
Sekunde, Leute.
Upload Song.
Sag mal, ich habe zu viele Tabs.
Mega Upload.
Ja, also was habe ich denn hier gerade gesehen?
Ein Windows Explorer Replay.
Guck mal da.
Google und Mega.
Das könnte man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Wo kann man das downloaden?
Microsoft Store.
MonkaS.
Okay, genug Mega Upload.
Reicht schon.
MonkaS.
Wer benutzt denn den Microsoft Store?
Gibt es den für Linux?
Ich fürchte mal nein.
So, wir gucken jetzt das FireShip Video, weil das immer nice, was der so treibt.
Guck ich gerne von dem immer schon kurz und knackig.
Mega ist der Nachfolger von Mega Upload.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Allerdings hat er das ja schon vor der ganzen Weile an die China Chinesen verkauft.
Ich weiß auch immer, die da treiben.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich meine nicht, dass das ursprünglich super vertrauenserweckend war oder so.
Schauen wir uns das mal an.
Zulu ist Band aufgrund von Black Facing.
Aha.
Okay, wenn das so ist.
Und warum ist dann das andere Zulu erlaubt und Zulu selber nicht?
Was auch immer.
Ich muss das alles nicht verstehen heutzutage.
Du vermisst den Windows Explorer.
Dolphin ist gut, aber ich mag den Windows Explorer.
Ich mag den Windows Explorer tatsächlich auch.
Und zwar für eine Sache, dass sie mittlerweile hier sowas wie Recent Files
drinne haben und ich in mein Vegas für Video bearbeite immer direkt von hier
tracken und droppen kann, den Rest benutze ich nicht.
Hatten die nicht mal?
Sagte mal, hat hat der Explorer unter Windows 11 nicht mittlerweile sogar Tabs?
Nee, soll er jetzt bekommen?
Das soll er schon seit fünf Jahren bekommen oder so.
So, also gucken wir uns mal das Fireship Video an.
Ten very promising Open Source Projects you haven't heard of.
Nachdem es Fireship ist und ich den gerne
gucke und nur 5 Minuten 28 mache ich jetzt nicht das, was ich bei solchen Videos
immer mache, einfach in die Beschreibung gucken und das Video skippen.
Ich habe zu viele Tabs.
Langsam, aber sicher habe ich habe ich echt auch für meine meine Begriffe zu viele Tabs.
So, schauen wir uns mal an.
Also Fireship. Erzähle uns, was ist?
Welche Open Source Projekte müssen wir benutzen?
I just discovered a way to build a billion
dollar start up entirely from free open source software from the most talented
programmers in the world. Actually, everybody knows that already.
Like why pay an engineer when you can just use their stuff for free on GitHub?
In today's video we're going to get off
the smart kids homework and look at some of the coolest open source libraries that
you've never heard of tools that will make your apps faster, better looking and less expensive.
Also Geld ausgeben, bezahlen ist ja wirklich cringe.
How have I not been using that already?
And that brings us to library number one.
The fuck normally when you.
Ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das haben wir sogar schon mal aus Spaß an der Freude im Stream verwendet.
Das ist eigentlich wirklich eine ganz gute Sache.
Aber ich konnte mich nie dazu durchringen,
the fuck zu verwenden als als Programm, wenn du dich verschreibst und dann in der
Kommandozeile eingibst, the fuck oder ich glaube nur fuck, dann auto korrigiert, dass
dein letztes Kommando wurde, dich verschrieben hast.
Fuck.
Normally, when you type a command into the terminal and make a typo in your head
and then retype the command from scratch, the fuck makes this process much more
intuitive, allowing you to simply type fuck into the terminal, then it will attempt
to reformat your command automatically, to be honest.
Ich meine mal ganz, ganz ernst.
Wenn das, wenn es dich sogar fragt.
Du hast dreimal schneller Note nochmal
neu getippt, anstatt fuck zu tippen und dann zu sagen Note Enter.
Also useful.
Das ist eher so
so fürs Meme in das Programm.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das wirklich so sinnvoll ist.
Hast du schon mal an Open Source Projekte gespendet?
Ja, habe ich doch gar nicht so lange her.
Ich habe Hardware gespendet.
Was heißt gespendet? Ja, doch kann man so nennen.
Ich habe Hardware gespendet und zwar an.
Moment, ich muss mein Hemd mal ein bisschen weg machen, das kratzt am Mikrofon.
GitHub, ATC, Thermometer.
Ich habe ihm hier drei Hardware
drei Thermometer gesponsert, dass er die
Firmware, die neueste, die neueste Firmware bzw.
die neueste Hardware Revision Reverse
engineeren kann, dass das Display funktioniert bei Revision 2 für das
Xiaomi Thermometer.
Natürlich muss ich jetzt auch mal ehrlich
halber sagen, natürlich nicht ganz unnützig, weil ich habe den Kram und es
hat nicht funktioniert. Ich habe zehn Stück bestellt bei AliExpress
und drei Stück habe ich gespendet.
Also insofern ja, ich habe schon mal gespendet für Projekte.
Und das ist nicht das einzige Mal.
Ich habe für Custom Firmware, für meine Kamera schon was gespendet.
Ansonsten fällt mir gerade nichts ein.
Hast du Erfahrung? Sekunde, was?
Hast du Erfahrung mit OpenVPN?
Möchte ein VPS Server ein Timelapse integrieren?
Ja, ich würde nicht OpenVPN nehmen.
Ich würde Wireshark, äh nicht Wireshark,
WireGuard nehmen.
Mittlerweile macht mein Boomer Gehirn da nicht mehr mit.
Außerdem ist es schon spät.
Ja, die Programme, die alle so ähnlich heißen.
So, jetzt gucken wir das Video aber jetzt mal am Stück, ohne dass ich permanent
hier unterbreche Problem, that anybody who's ever built a website is faced.
It's too slow.
Even if you work really hard to create a tiny JavaScript bundle, the product
manager will eventually tell you to add a bunch of other stuff like Mixpanel,
Intercom and Google Analytics.
These third party scripts clog up the main thread and will make your app slow no matter what.
Luckily, there's an open source library called PartyTown that can run
both party scripts from a WebWorker.
Javascript is single-threaded, but modern browsers allow you to run background jobs via WebWorkers.
PartyTown will offload in a script.
Leider ist Multithreading im Browser wirklich PainsChamp hoch 10.
Leider.
...that don't deal directly with the UI into a WebWorker.
And that means the only thing on the main thread is your UI.
Oh nein, TOS-Musik, TOS-Musik, TOS-Musik.
A new problem that every app developer will need to solve is user authentication.
Firebase is great, but it's somewhat feature-limited.
Muss man nicht. Solange man kein Login für seine Seite braucht, ist alles in Ordnung.
Auth0 is great, but it's expensive.
And that brings us to Super Tokens, which is an open source authentication solution.
It provides SDKs for runtimes like Node
and Python, allowing you to quickly self-host a fully-featured authentication
system with support for OAuth providers, passwordless login.
But most importantly, it deals with session management and security.
Pretty cool.
But it's got nothing on this next one.
HiMom is a blazingly fast JavaScript library that can say hi to your mom in record time.
Here's a pro tip.
Wait a minute.
Ist das jetzt ein Witz oder gibt es das wirklich?
No, God!
Warum gibt es denn für alles eine JavaScript Library alles?
Blazing fast JavaScript Library to say hi to...
Das ist ein Witz, ne?
Das ist 100% Witz.
Das ist so so Meme Library, um zu zeigen, ja,
JavaScript Libraries, keck weh.
If you're building an open source library, make sure that the README includes
phrases like blazingly fast, bleeding edge, holistic approach, and game changing because they make your library better.
The same way putting Flamestickers on a car makes it go faster.
Next up we have a two for one.
Many businesses out there need to build
their own full-text search engine, either for internal data or to build a search
engine for their customers. You could go with Elasticsearch, but it's expensive and
complicated if you self-host. There are two very promising open source...
Soll ich euch mal einen Trick verraten?
Du kannst das meiste, was du an Datenbanken
brauchst, was du an relationalen Datenbanken brauchst, was du an
time series Datenbanken brauchst, was du an
instrumentbasierten Datenbanken brauchst, was du an
Fulltext Search und was du an Autocomplete und Text Indexing brauchst, was du kannst
fast alles mit Postgres erschlagen, fast alles.
Die haben Postgres kann alles.
Du brauchst eigentlich gar nichts anderes mehr.
Das Problem ist nur, dass man sich erst mal ein bisschen durchkämpfen muss.
Aber eigentlich kann Postgres quasi
im Prinzip könntest du fast 90 prozent dieser Dinge einstellen und durch Postgres ersetzen.
Alternatives one is Melee search implemented in Rust and the other is Zynq implemented in Go.
Okay, okay.
Erleichtert dadurch, dass es in Rust implementiert ist,
werden die Leute das benutzen.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin ja bei manchen Sachen.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Also ich muss sagen, normalerweise bin ich ja sehr.
Wie nennt man das? Pragmatisch bei dem, was ich verwende.
Also wenn ich ein Produkt sehe, was passt, dann denke ich mir okay.
Warum nicht? Ja, kann man verwenden, auch wenn ich
vielleicht anderes von denen nicht mag, ist ja egal.
Aber in dem Fall manchmal bin ich da so ein bisschen impulsiv, auch bei der
Entscheidung, und zwar wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste.
Jetzt hier. Ich habe beides noch nie benutzt.
Wenn ich mich zwischen Melee Search oder oder Zynq entscheiden müsste, würde ich
Melee Search nehmen, weil die Webseite besser aussieht und ein hübsches Logo haben.
Implementiert.
Das ist die Qualität der Software aus.
Aber wahrscheinlich würde ich mir deswegen das zuerst mal.
Und Rust. Und es ist in Rust programmiert.
In Rust programmiert sein hat in dem Fall für mich tatsächlich einen Vorteil.
Wenn ich das nämlich embedden will, wenn ich das embedden will,
ist das mit Rust.
Also mal angenommen, ich mache mal meine C-Sharp-Web-Anwendung
ASP.NET Core, da ist Interop mit Rust um Längen, um Welten einfacher als mit Go.
Interop mit Go ist Müll.
Go funktioniert gut mit Go und sonst nix.
Interop mit Go ist Abfuck.
Also C-Interfaces für Go ist komplett für den Arsch.
Und dann hast du das Problem, dass Go Calls,
also Calls in Go rein, übelsten Overhead haben und
Calls quasi von Go nach C, nee umgedreht, Calls von Go nach C übelsten Overhead
haben und Calls von unmanaged in Go rein noch mehr Overhead haben.
Das macht bei den meisten Sachen zwar keinen
großartigen Unterschied, aber es nervt mich.
Und ja, ich weiß, das ist im Prinzip egal, wenn du irgendwelche Web-Requests schickst.
Aber wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, das
irgendwie zu embedden, ist natürlich noch cooler.
Da musst du keinen extra
Web-Service noch zusätzlich laufen lassen oder sowas.
Also da ist ein bisschen Rust.
Rust besser. Ich mein, C-Interfaces in Rust ist wirklich einfach.
Ja, Rust ist nur für High-IQ-Leute.
Allein schon die Rust-Syntax.
Die Rust-Syntax ist im Vergleich zu C++ logisch, aber kompliziert.
Und C++ ist
kompliziert, weil unlogisch und übertrieben bloatet.
Ist es nicht einfach mittlerweile so, dass
Go statt Python genommen wird und Rust statt C? Nö.
Es hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung, vielleicht mal außer C++, aber...
Nein, sogar C++, gerade wenn man in der Game-Entwicklung guckt.
Da ist ja alles irgendwie in C++.
Unreal ist in C++.
Unity ist ja auch intern in C++, glaube ich, oder C?
Nee, ich glaube C++.
Zum Glück kompilieren die C-Sharp nach C++ und dann kann man das halbwegs ertragen.
Und Go und Python kannst du schlecht das eine durch das andere ablösen,
weil es einfach komplett unterschiedliche Ansätze hat.
Was ist denn bitteschön nicht bloatet?
Ich...
Da hat der ByteStrike recht.
Die Chatbrain-IDEs, die sind auch bloatet, aber gut bloatet.
Notepad ist nicht bloatet.
Ja, ganz ehrlich,
gRPC wollte ich tatsächlich auch schon mich längere Zeit mal intensiver mit beschäftigen.
Ich habe immer mal am
Lande so ein bisschen was gemacht, aber nie großartig was.
Und ich glaube, das ist was.
Das brauchst du wahrscheinlich nicht heute.
Also das brauchst du nicht jeden Tag.
Aber wenn du es brauchst und ein bisschen Ahnung davon hast, dass du genau einschätzen
kannst, wann du es benutzen solltest, ist das, glaube ich, eine richtig gute Geschichte.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal mit gRPC was gemacht?
Also ich stelle es mir wirklich cool vor.
Für bestimmte Sachen.
Mir fällt jetzt kein Beispiel ein.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwelche
Sachen streamen willst oder so.
Also irgendwelche Daten streamen willst, die auf dem Server generiert werden
und auf den Client gestreamt werden sollen oder irgendwie sowieso Geschichten.
Also da stelle ich mir schon ziemlich cool vor.
Aber ich habe damit kaum was gemacht bisher.
Aber ich glaube, es ist wirklich nice.
Und wenn man sich damit beschäftigt hat,
dann weiß man nämlich auch, wann man es gut gebrauchen kann.
Hallo, unser Haus hat einen Kabelanschluss, aber in der Wohnung im Erdgeschoss gibt es
nicht nur eine TAE-Dose.
Was für einen Aufwand ist das, eine Kabeldose zu machen?
Wo hast du denn einen Kabelanschluss dann?
Im Keller oder was?
Naja, du müsstest.
Du müsstest irgendwie, wenn du das, wenn du das haben willst,
du müsstest halt irgendwie ein Coax-Kabel ins Erdgeschoss bekommen.
Wo hast du denn den Kabelanschluss?
Komplett raus aus dem Thema.
Der kommt bei dir im Keller raus oder wie?
Und ja gut, da musst du irgendwie ein Kabel hochlegen, wenn du es im Erdgeschoss haben willst.
Anders geht das nicht.
Ja, da geht es doch gerade darum.
Er hat im Keller einen Kabelanschluss, aber im ersten Stock hat er bloß eine
Telefondose und deswegen hat er keinen Kabelanschluss.
Ach so, ja gut, wenn die nicht mal dir ist,
das muss dann eh dein Vermieter machen, du kannst ja nicht einfach die Wand bohren.
Wenn das nicht dir ist, musst du dem sagen.
Sag hier, gib her, give please.
Je nachdem, was du machen willst, wenn du Fernsehen gucken willst, bringt dir
das nicht allzu viel.
Es sei denn, du machst sowas wie DVB-C-Tuner
unten und dann über IP drüber und so, also je nachdem, was man machen will.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, der Keller und die Wohnung gehört dir eh nicht.
Also kannst du da eh nichts selbst bohren.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Es kommt darauf an, wie sehr du dich auskennst.
Ich weiß nicht, was man als Informatik, Informatik-Techniker so lernen muss.
Aber ganz ehrlich, was man physitechnisch lernt,
ist auch nicht super kompliziert und.
Kriegen die meisten auch easy hin, also wirst du das wahrscheinlich auch schaffen.
Wie sinnvoll findest du es, dass ein Fachinformatik-Anwendungsentwicklung im
fünften Ausbildungsmonat eine Cloud- und Data-Center-Admin-Zertifizierung für
Ernsthaft, dafür gibt es Zertifizierung?
Wirklich?
Jaira-Zertifizierung?
Ich müsste ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was daran irgendwie.
Was man damit anfangen soll.
Aber hey, wenn es sein Arbeitgeber toll findet und im Endeffekt unserem Strich
dadurch vielleicht auch mal mehr springen lässt, warum nicht?
Ja, wenn du den Kram bezahlt kriegst.
Mach's. Warum nicht?
Bock hätte ich auch nicht drauf, sage ich dir ganz ehrlich.
So, wir müssen jetzt endlich mal das Video fertig gucken.
Without the need for schemas or cogeneration like you would with GraphQL.
Overall, I think it has the potential to fundamentally simplify the way we build
full-stack web applications.
Speaking of simplification, one company that has simplified the modern
database is Airtable. The only problem
habe ich noch nie benutzt. Jemand von euch schon mal Airtable benutzt?
Problem is that you have to pay a company to use it.
If only there was an open source alternative.
NOCO DB does exactly that.
It's an open source Airtable that can be built on top of your own MySQL or Postgres.
Moment, das ist ein Aufsatz auf meine Postgres.
Warum verwende ich nicht meine Postgres einfach
so? Also wozu brauche ich das?
Es ist ja nicht so, mein Postgres kann ja quasi alles zum größten Teil, was so
ziemlich alles andere auch kann. Also, mein Postgres ist quasi in ein Produkt,
fünf Produkte in einem von dem, was sie können.
Also, hä?
In other words, it's an open source, no-code database or smart spreadsheet.
Ach, das ist was, wo sich die Noobs irgendwelche Excel-Tabellen zusammenklicken können.
Ach so.
Das ist, dass die Personalabteilung sich
irgendwelche Spreadsheets zusammenbasteln kann.
Oder wie? Ach, so ist es.
Oh Gott, nee, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Geh mal weg.
Float the game. Dankeschön.
Elf Monate Entwicklung.
Spreadsheet as a developer.
Another piece of software you may want to replace is Postman, your HTTP client.
An awesome open source alternative is Hopscotch, which is built...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Wir verwenden schon lange kein Postman mehr.
Wir gehen mit der Zeit.
Wir verwenden Postwoman.
Und das ist jetzt kein Witz, das gibt's wirklich.
They want to replace is Postman, your HTTP client.
An awesome open source alternative is
Hopscotch, which is built with Vue.js and TypeScript entirely as a progressive web app.
Dann ist es natürlich besser, wenn sie in Vue.js und TypeScript entwickelt ist.
Muss das besser sein.
But you can go use it in the browser right now at Hopscotch.io
and then install it as a PWA on your desktop.
And now it runs in a native window and allows you to interact with your file system.
Now, if you've ever coded
in Python, then tried JavaScript later, you might be shocked at how difficult it is.
Weiß, hast du mir das nicht geglaubt, dass es das gibt?
Das war kein Chibay, das gibt's wirklich.
Ach, das ist Hopscotch.
Lull.
Ach, Postwoman heißt jetzt Hopscotch.
Das ist zu wahr.
... it is to work with multidimensional arrays.
What is this?
In Python we have libraries like Pandas that can do all kinds of useful stuff to an array or data frame.
Not many people realize that there's a library called Danfoe.js.
Danfoe.js hab ich auch noch nie gehört.
Powerful JavaScript Data Analysis Tool.
Das ist mir zu advanced.
Gar nicht die Überschrift.
... that is inspired by Pandas and can do many of the things you know and love,
like read a CSV file and process the data within it before it gets sent to a machine
learning library like TensorFlow.
That's pretty useful.
But the hardest thing in front-end web development...
Seriously, seriously.
Ich glaube, ich wusste noch nie,
wie in JavaScript eine CSV-Datei verarbeiten.
Aber das mag anders sein, wenn man Node im Backend verwendet.
Dann muss man so eklige Dinger manchmal machen, aber...
Ich bin eh glücklicherweise um CSV-Dateien in den letzten Jahren
zum größten Teil rumgekommen.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit eine CSV-Datei, aber ansonsten...
Also eine riesen CSV-Datei, aber ansonsten...
Moin Open Source Leko.
... can your website look good.
There's a million different tools out there that can help you do that.
But one I've been really loving recently for React is Mantine.
Der immer mit seinem React-Zeug.
... like this nice looking timeline, but it also has a bunch of built-in hooks
that handle many of the annoying things that you'll come across when building a web app.
Was können CSV-Dateien schlecht lesbar im Editor sein?
Können die, das können die ziemlich gut.
Und sich mit Fehlern in
Tabellenkalkulation importieren lassen, weil man nicht den richtigen Separator
verwendet hat.
... a collection of items.
On top of that, it has optional packages for a notification system,
rich text editor and a drop zone for file uploads.
It's so awesome that we use it in one of the demo apps in the full React course
on Fireship.io. Check it out if you want to build a serious app with React.
Now the problem with all the libraries that we've looked at so far is that they require you to know how to write some code.
If you have an idea for a full stack application, but want to skip the whole
learn to code part, an open source tool to check out is Amplication.
It's a tool that can automatically
generate both your frontend and backend code based on relationships to data models.
Und ich generate mein Frontend und mein Backend aus irgendeinem Datenbankschema.
Jetzt wird's aber pfeiffertig.
Ob da was Gescheites rauskommt?
... in a database that you can manage visually.
The backend is built with other open source tools like Node, NestJS and Prisma,
while the frontend is based on React.
Even if you do know how to code, this is a tool that can speed up your workflow.
Okay, der ist halt einfach ein Riesen-React-Fan der Kerl.
... open source libraries to try out in your next project.
Hit the like button and subscribe.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Ähm, ähm, nur, dass ich das, Chat, Chat, nur, dass ich jetzt euch richtig verstehe,
oder Wollo, dass ich dich richtig verstehe.
Ihr habt auf der Arbeit 1,5 petabyte CSV-Dateien.
Wirklich.
Das ist, das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das aushalten würde.
Ist ja nicht ursprünglich mal Angular-Entwickler gewesen.
Möglich, möglich, ja.
Aber irgendwann muss früher oder später ja mal jeder merken,
was so Mist ist.
Ich verstehe vieles an Excel nicht.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ernsthaft?
Ja gut, das war wahrscheinlich zu Zeiten, wo Angular noch nicht ein riesengroßes bloated mess war.
Angular kann man immer gut flamen.
Excel-Datenbanken beste.
Ich dachte, Access-Datenbanken sind die besten.
Gibt es, gibt es Access eigentlich noch?
Scheiße, das gibt es ja immer noch.
Sachen, es gibt Sachen, die sterben einfach nicht.
No, God!
No, God, please, no, no, no, no!
Access.
Boah, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Die wollen wir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen.
Das sieht aus wie ein Programm aus
2022, Mann.
Das sieht aus wie ein Programm von 1998 immer noch.
Access.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus, ey.
Ja, in der Schule sollten
wir auch mal was mit Access machen.
Das war bei dem Lehrer, Recycle Story Incoming, das kennt er ja schon.
Das war bei dem Lehrer, der eigentlich
keine Ahnung von Computer-Krams und IT und sonst was hatte, wo wir quasi zweieinhalb
Jahre oder drei Jahre in diesem Fach, was ich, ich glaube, IT-Systeme oder irgendwie
nannte, haben wir Office gemacht. Und das Einzige, worauf du bei dem Lehrer achten
musst, ist richtig ByteStrikes, du weißt das noch, dass du deine Office-Dokumente lila gemacht hast.
Und dann hat er sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, oh, Leila, Leila, Leila, du hast da eins gekriegt.
Das war
WeirdChamp.
Ganz grausam.
Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Das habe ich nie verdaut, ey.
IT-Unterricht in der Schule von jemand, der absolut keine Ahnung hat.
Was geht mit der Mario-Karten-Musik ab?
Die ist ja sehr hartnäckig gerade.
Ja, besser. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
PlayStation-3-Emulation auf dem PC ist impressive.
Das würde mich wundern, wenn das gescheit funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich ist PS3-Emulation impressive, weil überhaupt mal jetzt ein Spiel startet.
I'm a big supporter of all things emulation.
And in today's episode, we're going to take a closer look at the advancements.
Jobs supporting most.
Moment, ist das?
Nee, das ist, das ist nicht.
Das ist nicht. Was ist denn das?
Not all, certainly not all PlayStation-3-Games.
And in the last six months or so, there's been some incredible advancements.
And it's really something that I want to talk about on the channel today.
RPCS3 is a PlayStation-3-Emulator that runs under Windows.
Und das funktioniert wirklich?
There is also a Linux-Version that you can try, as well as a Mac-Version that's currently in development.
When it comes to emulation, attempting to emulate a PS3 properly
stands at the top of the list.
Also PS3-Emulator stands at the top of the mountain as the single most complex thing that you could possibly do.
Yeah, I've covered the complexity.
Ohne Scheiß, PS3-Emulator ist, also generell PS3-Hardware ist absolutes Hexenwerk.
Hat man ja gesehen, dass die Entwickler auf der Original-Hardware Jahre gebraucht
haben, bis sie das überhaupt ordentlich verwenden konnten.
Aber ich muss sagen,
die PS3 war die letzte Konsolen-Hardware, die wirklich,
wie soll ich sagen, so,
die wirklich überrascht und begeistert hat.
Jetzt ist das mehr oder weniger so 0815-PC-Zeug.
Aber es hat sich halt nicht wirklich gelohnt.
...of the PS3-Hardware in terms of making games for it, as well as emulating one for past episodes.
And if you're interested, I'll leave links to those in the description below.
Ich habe ja noch vor Jahren gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass wir überhaupt jemals in naher Zukunft einen PS3-Emulator sehen werden.
Aber da lag ich anscheinend falsch.
Now, over on the RPCS3-Website, you can simply just download the latest version of the emulator.
Moment, ich muss da mal kurz hin.
Ich muss da mal kurz hin.
Wir machen das mit der VM.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Seite MonkaTOS ist.
Wer weiß, was man da so runtergeschoben kriegt?
Wahrscheinlich nix.
Ich mach mal kurz die VM an.
Ich will mal kurz gucken, wie
viele Spiele kompatibel sind.
Wie heißt, wie hieß dieses Ding?
RPCS3.
RPCS3 ist ein C++-Entwickel, das ist ja schon mal wieder grausam.
So, compatibility.
Playable.
Ja gut, Playable, jetzt wäre die Frage, kann man das durchspielen?
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal.
Wie sieht es denn aus mit
Call of Duty?
Modern Warfare ist Playable.
Blu-Ray.
Digital.
Anscheinend funktioniert das ohne Probleme, außer dass es ab und zu crasht.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Das allen Ernstes da drauf, was was wirklich durchspielbar lauffähig ist.
Wie ist denn die Performance so?
Das werden wir gleich sehen, denke ich.
We have options for both Windows and Linux.
And as mentioned, Mac is on the way, but it's currently not available.
But Mac will come out at some point.
So check that out.
Die müssen wahrscheinlich erst noch mal
die Metal-Dokumentation lesen, dass sie den Kram bei Apple zum Laufen bekommen.
All you need to do at this point is download either a Windows build.
And if you do that,
it'll just download onto your desktop here and then just extract that into a folder.
And then all you need to do at that point is run the RPCS3 executable.
Now, once you've downloaded and extracted
RPCS3, the first time you run it, you need to install a firmware.
So the PlayStation 3
Also im Prinzip, im Prinzip der gleiche Spaß wie bei der PS1, was die Emulatoren
heute noch nicht mitliefern dürfen.
Many different libraries that do many different things and all these games that
on PlayStation 3 reference these libraries.
Now, the way that it works is you simply
install the PlayStation 3 firmware via RPCS3.
And it probably takes about a minute or so once that's done.
Und dann lädt es runter von Sony.
You're all pretty much set to go.
Now, I will mention that you do need a
pretty solid and beefy piece of hardware to run RPCS3.
Now, if we take a look at the Quick Start Guide, you can see that the minimum
requirements here is basically...
Any X64 CPU.
Okay, das natürlich, das natürlich hab ich.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich wundere, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Also es ist absoluter Wahnsinn, die PlayStation 3 zu emulieren.
Weil die PlayStation Hardware nichts, aber
auch gar nichts mit so einem Standard PC zu tun hat.
CPU or any X64 Intel CPU and anything that runs OpenGL 4.3 or higher.
With four gigabytes of RAM.
Now, I will tell you that nothing is
really going to run very well with those specifications.
You might get away with some of the smaller releases that are out there that
don't take advantage of the SPUs and maybe some homebrew stuff.
But ultimately, you're not really going to get a great experience.
Now, the website recommends a six core,
12 thread or eight cores or more Skylake architecture or newer.
I would even argue
that even Skylake isn't necessarily going to give you a great experience.
Also, allein schon, dass das läuft, ist wirklich eine Riesenleistung.
Das muss man wirklich mal anerkennen.
Also PlayStation 3 Emulator, das hat er schon ganz richtig gesagt.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich eines der
krassesten Dinger sein, die man überhaupt entwickeln kann.
I'm running a 10th generation Intel i7 and I will say that it runs things pretty
well for the most part, but there are still some games that have slowdown issues.
Now, in the past to test the emulation,
you would need to install a game first to see if things were running properly.
But that is no longer the case because
the firmware file also contains the virtual shell or cross media bar dashboard.
And with a recent update on January the 3rd of 2022,
it is now possible to boot into the VSH and run the cross media bar UI
with any PlayStation 3 firmware.
And this is a significant update for many reasons.
Most emulators out there don't really
seem to bother with the user interface.
They're more really focused on playing games.
But this is a significant update to RPCS3.
Kann man da auch den PlayStation Store verwenden?
Das wird nicht funktionieren, oder?
To see the fruits of the work that's being done over the years and the compatibility
level is only increasing over time.
I should also mention that the RPCS3 devs are working on fixing the missing audio
and implementing the web browser in the XMB.
Nee, geht nicht.
Nee, hätte mich auch sehr gewundert, wenn das funktionieren würde.
Also other things that are being worked on.
To launch into the cross media bar,
simply select boot VSH slash XMB from the file menu.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, was das sein soll.
Was lauscht man?
Konnte man nicht Linux auf der PS3 installieren?
Doch, wahrscheinlich kannst du da Linux laufen lassen im Emulator, was natürlich
maximal sinnlos ist, aber es müsste, müsste funktionieren.
Ja.
To compile up all the PPU and SPU caches.
But this is a one and done type of deal.
Once everything has been cached, booting
into the XMB the second time round will be much faster.
Moin Schiebler Schieberfuchs.
Ich mein, du könntest damit theoretisch
unter Linux eine PS3 emulieren, auf der du dann das PS3 Linux startest.
Unsinnig, aber es müsste funktionieren.
Ich mein, da drinne, da drinne
kannst du dann auch wirklich die, die scammigste Webseite öffnen.
Du wirst auf dem Browser wahrscheinlich mit, was war das?
Yellow Dog, Linux oder sowas auf der PS3
wirst wahrscheinlich keine, keine ordentliche Webseite anzeigen lassen
können, aber wahrscheinlich kannst du Flash Games darin dann spielen.
Aber da kannst du echt die scammigste Webseite anzeigen.
Musst dir keine Gedanken machen, dass da irgendjemand ausbricht.
One of the other things that I really like
before I get stuck into RPCS3 is configure my gamepad.
Now, if we go into the pads menu here, I have a DualShock4 plugged into my PC
and I can simply just select it from the drop down here.
It has kind of presets here.
If you're plugging in a DualShock3 or a DualShock4,
it even has a preset for the DualSense as well.
And if you have just a generic X-input base as well.
But I definitely recommend that you use a gamepad.
Das läuft doch ganz okay.
Das ruckelt schon. Das ruckelt ziemlich.
Guckt euch das mal an.
RPCS3. Das ruckelt ziemlich.
Das sind.
Keine Ahnung, 12, 13 FPS oder sowas.
The keyboard, of course, but I would probably recommend that you don't do that.
But once you've got your pad all configured as well, then really now
21? Echt? Es ruckelt auf jeden Fall.
So if we take a closer look at the compatibility list, there's been some
significant advancements here as well. You can see that there's
3,250 games that are on the database.
And of those, there's 2069, which is a percentage of 63.66%.
And the definition of playable here are games that can be completed with
playable performance and no game breaking glitches.
And that is a pretty high percentage.
The last time we looked at this, it was in the high 50s.
As of the making of this episode, the compatibility list is almost at 60%
of the entire PS3 library as playable, with a further 33.5% as getting in-game.
Another major milestone is that back in October of 2021, the RPCS3 team announced
that every single PS3 game now boots into the emulation.
In other words, there is 0% in the nothing.
Also ganz ehrlich, sowas zu programmieren ist wirklich massives Pfeilfett.
Wollen wir mal auf Git? Warte mal, warte mal, nur mal ganz kurz.
Github, wie heißt dieses Ding?
Ja, wir gucken uns da nicht viel an.
Wir gucken uns da nicht viel an.
Ich will, ich will nur mal, ich will das
nur mal aufmachen und mal zeigen, wie viel, wie viel das ist.
Die haben doch hier immer Analyse.
Konnte man sich nicht line of
dachte, man konnte Codezeilen irgendwie
zählen oder hat nämlich so ein Statistik Ding Insights.
Genau. Oh, wo ist das noch mal versteckt?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Darwin.
Ute, das ist Meck.
Es ist C++.
Ah, jetzt ist es.
Ach ja, obvius, obvius, obvius.
Alles klar, hier wird hier wird
wahrscheinlich das Game Binary irgendwie, weil die müssen ja quasi die die die Codes,
die also die Instruktionen in dem Game Binary müssen die ja quasi on the fly
umschreiben in x86 Instruktionen.
Was halt Messe Feifert Shit ist.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an.
Ey, was auch immer.
Aber gut, in Köln.
The team has also been very busy fixing
graphical issues over the past few months and overall improving the emulation
accuracy, notably issues addressed with immediate mode rendering.
Dann ist der Emulator auch auf 30 FPS gelockt.
Die PS3 war nie auf 30 FPS.
Gelockt.
Issues that were found in games such as Ratchet and Clank, Uncharted 1, 2 and 3
and The Last of Us, and now there's also recent updates to fix lighting issues as
well as things like dynamic shadows.
I've spent the past few days testing the updates out for myself and I gotta say
I'm impressed with how well things have quickly progressed along.
The team really seems to have hit their stride.
And while there's still lots of work to do.
Well, just take a look.
Nein, in der PS3 ist kein X6.
In der PS3 ist eine Mischung aus Power, Power PC, IBM Power PC und ich glaube
sechs so Rechenkerne noch.
Das hat mit X6, also es könnte kaum
weiter entfernt von normaler X86 Architektur sein.
For yourself.
Ich meine, das läuft doch erstaunlich gut.
Für das, dass es mal einfach PS3 Spiele auf dem PC sind.
Lost it.
What am I doing wrong?
Am I not powerful enough?
Genau, Power PC plus Custom Bullshit.
Was wird die PlayStation 4 ist ein ziemlich normaler PC.
Ja, das stimmt.
Was lustig ist, ich habe das schon öfters erzählt an der Stelle, aber ich fand die
Story damals echt spannend, die haben also bei IBM wurde die CPU entwickelt,
sowohl für die Xbox 360 als auch für die PS3 und mehr oder weniger von den
gleichen Leuten, die offiziell nichts voneinander wissen durften.
Das ist richtig.
Gibt sogar ein Buch drüber.
Das finde ich, fand ich echt spannende Geschichte.
Und fragt mich, wie die das gemacht haben.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir nur noch Gameplay.
Games like the Emulator itself.
This is still very much a work in progress.
Ich finde das cool, dass es einfach geht.
Mittlerweile.
Und man muss ja wirklich sagen, dass es einfach geht.
Jedes Spiel bootet.
Installation ist relativ easy.
Also
das ist wirklich echt ein Achievement.
Das ist wirklich Hut ab.
Also PlayStation 3 Emulator ist echt absolut krasse Geschichte.
We are going to continue to follow this Emulator over the course of the year.
Ihr sollt mal Dings spielen, ob Little Big Planet läuft.
Little Big Planet war nice.
Ob da Multiplayer funktioniert?
Das ist die Frage, ob du dich online überhaupt connecten kannst ins PSN.
Wenn ich ins PSN connecten kann, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Multiplayer funktioniert.
Aber keine Ahnung.
I don't recommend Ubuntu anymore.
Oh ne, ist es der Dude, der uns letztens erzählt hat, warum er kein Firefox mehr...
Hey guys, this is Nick and Ubuntu got me into Linux in 2008.
Ne.
Das gucken wir nicht.
Es ist der Kerl, der letztens erzählt hat, er verwendet kein Firefox mehr, dafür
den Gnome Browser und an einem Video danach zu sagen Ach nee, war doch keine so gute Idee.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir das nicht gleich gewusst.
Der hat wirklich Critical Informations geleckt.
Blizzard's massive gamble is failing.
Why?
Okay, Level Cap, wir lassen uns, wir lassen uns noch einmal chippen.
Kommt der tägliche Level Cap chippen.
Ganz ehrlich, Overwatch 2 hyped mich so überhaupt nicht.
... Elden Ring Cheaters are ruining save files and much more on today in gaming.
Hey guys, Level Cap here.
The PC Beta for Overwatch 2
starts on April 26th.
It will offer PvP Matches on new maps with a new...
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich noch ein paar von den alten Leuten da wieder ein bisschen
aktivieren kann, mit denen ich viel Overwatch gespielt habe, vielleicht gucken
wir uns das mal an zusammen, aber wohl eher nicht im Stream.
Ich meine, ich habe hunderte Stunden, wenn
ich tausende Stunden Overwatch gespielt und
ich meine, ich war alleine
in der Beta Level 300 oder so was.
Oder Level 500 in der Beta, ich war übertrieben hoch in der Beta schon.
Und es ist einfach Pain's Champ, was Blizzard mit dem Game gemacht hat.
... Hero called Sojourn and it reworks
existing Heroes Orisa, Doomfist, Bastion and Sombra.
Signups are currently live on Blizzard's
website for the game and there will be multiple beta phases before launch.
So if you don't get into this one,
chances are that you'll get into one later on.
The beta will feature four new maps called Circuit Royale, Midtown, Toronto and
Rome.
Wie viele neue Maps?
Circuit Royale, Midtown, Toronto and Rome.
... called Circuit Royale, Midtown, Toronto and Rome later on.
The beta will feature four new maps called Circuit Royale, Midtown, Toronto and Rome later on.
Vier neue Maps, also ohne Scheiß.
Overwatch 2, die können ja wieder anfangen mit
wir machen drei neue Maps in drei Jahren und so was.
Eigentlich müsste das gleich mal 20 neue Maps geben oder so, aber naja, naja.
Hab da meine Zweifel.
... offer a new game mode called Push.
Across all maps and modes,
a new ping system will be available to help communicate with your teammates.
The betas are being done in part because,
well, the fifth season of Overwatch League starts in May and it's going to be using
Overwatch 2. League players have already been practicing on beta builds of the game,
but opening up the beta to the general population will help the devs uncover
balance issues or technical problems the pros might have not encountered yet.
And while this news should sound exciting in general, it is happening.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr,
dass Lucio und
ursprünglich, jetzt wo ich das hier gerade sehe,
Wusstet ihr, dass Lucio ursprünglich ein Eishockey-Spieler sein sollte aus Kanada?
In der Entwicklungsphase.
Und jetzt ist es halt so krasser DJ aus Südamerika.
Was? Hey Max, gestern mal wieder dein Schneestelzen-Video gesehen.
Immer noch wieder toll, wenn das vorgeschlagen wird.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was mit dem YouTube-Algorithmus los ist.
Keine Ahnung.
And while this news should sound exciting in general, it is happening within the shadow of Activision Blizzard's
Workplace-Harassment-Controversy.
The State of California's ongoing lawsuit against the company details years of abuse, harassment, assaults and more.
Ja, das hat ja nicht direkt was mit Overwatch zu tun, das ist ja komplett Blizzard-Shit.
Recently a Wall Street Journal report implicated CEO Bobby Kotick
had played a role in suppressing the allegations.
Was? Nein, da wird ja nie einer dran gedacht, dass Bobby mit am...
Nein, das hätte man ja nicht mit rechnen können.
...Kotick shielded at least one senior employee from the consequences...
Ganz ehrlich, Bobby ist das doch alles scheißegal.
Wenn es dazu führt,
dass der Rubel rollt, geht das dem am Arsch vorbei.
Denen interessiert das erst, wenn es Geld kostet.
Ansonsten ist das...
Es war doch gar keine Frage, ob er das wusste oder nicht.
Natürlich wusste er das alles.
...Colonel investigation that found him guilty of assaulting a junior employee.
Xbox-Head Phil Spencer quickly negotiated a buyout of Activision Blizzard with Kotick
barely 24 hours after the Wall Street Journal...
Obwohl er vorher noch ein paar Wochen gesagt, äh, vor ein paar Tagen davor
gemacht hat, hat so nach dem Motto, nee, nee, nee, Activision, nee, nee,
mit denen wollen wir nichts zu tun haben.
...Journals report.
On top of these allegations,
Covid forced Activision Blizzard to rework its live event plans in early 2021.
They decided to focus more on online
events and subsequently laid off 50 employees from their live events group.
Und all of this...
Ja, Overwatch League ist ja auch failes.
...overwatch league sponsorship deals.
Typically, big esports tournaments have dozens of official sponsorships that help
Overwatch League nicht.
...but not a single sponsorship
has been announced for the upcoming Overwatch League season.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, seit der Krempel
auf YouTube ist, guckt das doch keine Sau mehr.
Sekunde. YouTube Overwatch League.
Hm.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an, das darf man sich bestimmt nicht angucken hier, weil,
weil, weil so und Zeug.
Ähm, guck mal hier.
Die Top 10 Plays haben 40.000 Views.
Und die letzten Matches
waren auch immer die Waren.
Guck mal.
Das hat 116.000 Views.
Das ist, das ist so, so.
Okay, guck mal.
Die Grand Finals hatten 800, das war ein Livestream.
Die Grand Finals hatten insgesamt 820.000.
Leute, also die haben nicht insgesamt geguckt, die haben halt mal reingeklickt.
Das ist, das ist halt, mittlerweile ist die Overwatch League auf einem Niveau, wo irgendein CSGO
regional...
Deswegen mehr Zuschauer hat.
...of the League's existing sponsors dropped out after the initial wave of workplace
harassment allegations made headlines last year.
Even Comcast, who owns an Overwatch League team, has confirmed that they will not be
sponsoring the League this season. Ultimately, it's tough to say what the
future holds for Overwatch, its esports scene and even Blizzard itself.
The acquisition by Xbox is sure to shake things up.
Hopefully it's all for the better.
But if Overwatch League can't attract new sponsors, who's to say how long Blizzard
will continue bankrolling it?
Unlike most esports leagues, Overwatch League gives its players salaries and
benefits, which is a lot to pay for on top of the usual expenses like production
costs and prize pools.
Overwatch League could be one of the first Blockbuster Leagues to fail.
In more positive Activision...
Wenn ihr mich fragt, ist Overwatch League schon eigentlich gefailt?
Schon die letzten drei Jahre?
...related news, 90.000 Cheaters were banned in a massive wave this past...
Ja, und 90.000 Cheater haben sich einen neuen Account gemacht.
Und haben sich dann gedacht, Activision...
Easy as fuck!
...last week from Call of Duty Warzone and Vanguard.
The cheaters were detected using the developer's Ricochet anti-cheat tool.
It's proving to be a much more effective
countermeasure to cheating than their previous tools.
However, these massive bans aren't exactly a new thing for Warzone.
Since Warzone's launch, Activision has banned 940.000 accounts.
Previous ban waves have taken out 50 or 60.000 players at once.
Ricochet gives the developers the ability
to detect cheaters in real time and shield legitimate players from them.
It does this in a variety of ways.
One is to make the cheaters deal one damage per shot.
That effectively makes it impossible for them to get a kill.
Footage of this happening has been...
Ich mein, allein schon, dass man so einen Stuss machen muss,
anstatt sie einfach zu bannen.
...been buzzing on social media for months and the devs recently confirmed
it's part of their reverse engineering process.
The next Witcher game is officially in...
Ich mein, immerhin. Immerhin.
Eben, das sieht man daran.
Es gibt noch Cheater und es gibt noch neue Cheats für das Spiel.
In Battlefield 2042 wurde die Weiterentwicklung von Cheats
irgendwie einen Monat nach Release eingestellt.
Das ist kein Witz.
Eine große, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, eine große Seite,
die Cheats verkauft, hat gesagt, wer einen Battlefield 2042 Cheat gekauft hat,
das ist ja ein Abo, ist ein Abo-Modell, dass die Cheats aktuell bleiben,
der, ähm,
bekommt keine Updates mehr und sein Abo kann, glaub ich,
wahlweise umgestellt werden auf, auf, äh, Warzone oder Apex oder sowas.
Wenn auch nicht mal, wenn auch nicht mal die Cheat-Hersteller ihre Cheats für den Game
updaten wollen, da weißt du Bescheid.
Development. CD Projekt Red announced that a new saga begins on all of their social media accounts.
Ja, das, das, das war ja schon gerüchtemäßig am Start, dass ein neues Witcher-Game in Entwicklung ist.
Aber da werden wir bestimmt noch drei
Jahre drauf warten müssen.
Ich kann euch sagen, warum die ihre Inhouse-Engine nicht mehr verwenden wollen.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie die in Cyberpunk verwendet und haben festgestellt,
die sind da mittlerweile so am Limit und kriegen Geschiss da drin nicht mehr gebacken.
Sie nehmen irgendwas, wo sie auch Leute finden, die damit Ahnung haben.
The title is being developed as part of a multi-year collaboration.
with Unreal's developer Epic Games.
They're covering the licensing and assistance with the engine tech.
Though it's unclear what CD Projekt Red are doing in exchange.
The next Witcher title will not be an Epic Games Store exclusive.
Unfortunately for Elden Ring players, their anti-cheat situation has become a bit dire.
Players are reporting an exploit being abused by hackers who invade them.
The invader crashes your game and when you reboot, you're stuck in a failing death loop.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das Exploit was discovered in Dark Souls 3, a previous title by Elden Ring's developer.
Hopefully they have a quick fix in the works.
From's anti-cheat and exploit detection isn't exactly well regarded.
Modders have created special tools and online modes specifically to combat cheating in Dark Souls titles over the years.
If you find yourself the victim of this Elden Ring exploit,
there is a Reddit post with detailed instructions on fixing it linked below.
The simple version is to force quit the game as soon as it loads your save, reopen it, open your map,
and spam the confirm button.
If you do it quickly enough, you should respond safe and sound.
Fortnite's latest season made a significant change to the gameplay.
Chat, verfolgt irgendjemand Fortnite von euch?
Wie kommt das an? Feiern das die Leute, dass
Building rauskommt oder nicht? Ich hatte es vorhin schon mal gefragt.
Ich habe aber nicht mal in den Chat geguckt.
Feiern das die Leute oder finden die das eher kacke?
Weil eigentlich ist Building also eines der Haupt, wie soll ich sagen, so Gameplay-Elemente von Fortnite.
...bein removed from casual mode.
It's part of the seasonal narrative and will be restored as the season progresses.
In the meantime, the devs have tweaked a few things to keep fights fair.
All the players will have a recharging over shield that gives them an extra 50 HP.
The default run speed will be faster.
Sliding or sprinting into a door will force it open.
And you can also mantle on ledges that are too tall to jump to normally.
Fortnite has dabbled with build free modes and events in the past, but they've generally
been limited to a specific area of the map.
Building is still enabled in competitive, creative and save the world mode.
The devs might be using data from this event to rework building when it's reintroduced.
Aha. Sniper Elite 5 is launching on May 26.
Sniper Elite, who cares?
The developers of the extremely popular Unity
game engine released a new tech demo and, well, frankly, it's incredible.
It's called Enemies and Showcases in...
Es ist eine Technik-Demo.
Die Dinger müssen immer gespeichert werden.
Es ist ein Overhaul-Charakter-System mit neuen Skin-Shaders,
real-time-Hair basierend auf Strähnen, Raytracing, native DLSS und mehr.
Viele Leute denken wahrscheinlich an Unity
als Indie-Engine für günstige Spiele.
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Das denkt doch mittlerweile keiner mehr.
Es werden so viele Spiele in Unity programmiert.
Es sind auch so viele richtig große, erfolgreiche Spiele in Unity.
Das ist doch...
Da denkt doch... Also wer heutzutage noch denkt, Unity
ist irgendwie ein, was weiß ich, der Bussimulator,
die Bussimulator-Engine oder so oder Slenderman 25 oder sowas.
Nein, das ist doch Schwachsinn.
Es gibt viele beeindruckende Unity-Title wie Escape from Tarkov und Rust.
Die Demo sieht viel kürzer aus.
Es wird interessant sein, was die Entwickler mit diesen
Updated-Tools machen können, wenn sie später dieses Jahr veröffentlicht werden.
Wenn ihr hier neu seid, wollte ich nur sagen, danke fürs Zuhören.
Ich hoffe, ihr genießt unsere Coverage.
If so, consider subscribing.
It'll keep you in the loop whenever I upload and helps these videos reach more viewers.
Es kommt dabei, den meisten Spielen,
nicht den meisten Spielern, die würden das doch überhaupt nicht merken.
Und ich behaupte mal, wenn man das ordentlich
macht, ist es auch nicht spürbar, außer du kennst dich wirklich gut damit aus.
Und die Entwickler verwenden, re-usen halt viele Teile aus der Engine.
Du merkst das doch überhaupt nicht.
In welchem Spiel was programmiert ist.
Warum war da ein Vibrations-Sound?
Weil Level Cap das gerne macht.
Von mir war da nicht.
Von mir bekommt ihr nur solche Sounds hier, um euch zu irritieren.
Teams, ja, Double-Shift, Cringe, Hackers Backpack.
Ich glaube, das haben wir schon.
Der Hackers, Hackers Backpack.
I Fix It Kid, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das kann man da tatsächlich reinmachen.
Why not?
Ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht
die allergeilste Werkzeug Qualität, aber das ist ein gutes Set.
Gerade die ganzen rare Bits, die man selten braucht.
Ich musste letztens meine Mikrowelle aufschrauben,
weil sie kaputt war.
Der Knopf ging nicht mehr auf und es stand noch eine Tasse mit Milch drin in der
Mikrowelle. Das heißt, ich konnte die nicht mal richtig hochheben und wegschmeißen.
So, und da musste ich letztens die Mikrowelle aufschrauben und gucken, wie man die
irgendwie aufkriegt, und da hat mir das I Fix It Toolkit tatsächlich einiges gebracht, weil
die Mikrowelle mit so super weirdchampigen Schrauben zu war.
Zahlst du deine Zahnarzttermine auch selber?
Nein, ist mir zu teuer.
Noch gar nichts.
Der steht in der Ecke und surfert vor sich hin.
Mikrowelle aufmachen natürlich nicht, wie sie an war.
Ich hab die vom Strom abgemacht, bisschen stehen lassen und dann abgeschraubt.
Ich mach die doch nicht auf, während die an ist.
Ich schweiß die aber auch bestimmt nicht weg, wenn eure Tasse drin steht.
Sollen wir uns das jetzt nochmal angucken?
Was? Can Wireshark spot hidden cameras for free?
Wie soll denn Wireshark Kameras finden?
Ich meine, du kannst, lass mal überlegen, was die uns da wieder zeigen könnten.
Ich meine, du kannst natürlich
Wifi Zeug mitschneiden und vielleicht irgendwie anhand der Signalstärke oder
sowas irgendwie erkennen, wo was sendet oder so.
Vielleicht.
Na ja, mal gucken.
Kann man's mal anschauen.
Denn du musst ja nicht im WLAN drin sein, um WLAN Packages zu empfangen.
Das ist ja das Schöne an WLAN.
WLAN geht über die über die Luft.
Unabhängig.
Also du kannst WLAN Pakete und du kannst WLAN Traffic prinzipiell ja
sein, ohne dass du in diesem WLAN drin bist.
Du kannst halt nicht lesen.
Also jeder, der auf der Straße ist, kann deinen WLAN Traffic sehen.
Aber er kann nicht reingucken.
Also bzw. in die Daten nicht reingucken.
Okay, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob wir gebetet werden in dem Video.
Mal gucken, ob wir gebetet werden.
Warum ist denn die Qualität so kacke?
Ja,
1080p.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das ist doch im Leben kein 1080.
Vielleicht muss ich hier mal umschalten.
Nein, 720p sieht besser aus als 1080p.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt sieht 1080p auch besser aus.
Okay.
Finally a vacation.
Das ist doch gestellt.
Come on, son.
Wow.
Oh my God, it's so pretty.
Hey, kiddo, why don't you go play outside?
Dad, shut the f*** up, I'm playing Minecraft.
Okay, fine.
Airbnb is tackling privacy concerns this morning after several customers found hidden
cameras at their rental properties.
The company told CBS News it takes privacy extremely seriously.
And there is absolutely no...
Ja, das ist so eine typische Company-Antwort.
Wenn du sagst, Jungs, ihr habt da Kacke gebaut, das und das funktioniert nicht.
Da kommt da immer, oh,
wir nehmen das aber sehr und sehr ernst und haben jetzt auch unsere Mitarbeiter
noch mal neu geschult, das hat höchste Priorität bei uns.
Ist immer so.
Ich meine, es müsste und es gibt es, das gibt es bestimmt.
Man müsste mal danach suchen.
Ein so Business Response Generator.
Weil die die ganzen öffentlichen
Meldungen, die immer rauskommen von irgendwelchen Unternehmen oder auch die
öffentlichen Statements, die lesen sich alle immer gleich.
Ah, okay, wo geht's denn los?
Okay, Kamera am Start.
Das Video ist mega langsam.
Leise, nicht langsam.
Was?
Was hat das denn jetzt mit Wireshark zu tun?
...WiFi to communicate, meaning we can use packet monitoring software like Wireshark
in order to detect the presence of the camera.
The best part is Wireshark is free and can probably...
Okay, weiter.
Ein K8, das ist bestimmt bei AliExpress oder so was.
Ein K18 Multifunction Anti-Spy Detektor.
Reicht dazu nicht einfach.
Ein Notebook mit WLAN?
Oder? Okay, mal gucken.
The lens here is surrounded by red LEDs,
which should cause a reflection in any lens that it's pointed at.
However, considering how tiny the lenses are in modern...
Okay, das sieht, das, das sieht mal höchst sus aus, wenn einer so rumläuft.
...spy cameras, it might be difficult to get into the right position to actually
cause a reflection in the lens that you're looking for.
The radio frequency detector can be turned up and down in order to detect devices
that are emitting radio signals. That makes it possible for us to track down
a large number of devices that are radiating.
Okay, weiter.
Was, was, was bin ich hier sehend überhaupt?
Okay, the field of view is incredibly
narrow. And then these antennas, like, I don't understand their purpose or how to use them.
I mean, I don't...
Du brauchst einen Empfänger für die bestimmten Frequenzen.
Das ist ja das Gute an WLAN.
Jedes Notebook mit WLAN hat einen Adapter, der auf den richtigen Frequenzen ist,
weil WLAN eben nun mal auf festen Frequenzen ist oder auf festen Bändern ist.
So.
And if I had to guess, this one is the one that's sending stuff out.
Was? Okay, was hat es jetzt mit Wireshift?
Wireshark zu Sekunde.
Ich muss mir das, ich muss da mal vorspulen.
Das sind jetzt so Pains Champs, kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Today we're going to show off that it can also be used for finding Wireshark to find its location using Wireshark alone.
Ja, natürlich, das dachte ich mir.
Du kannst ja die, du kannst ja in Wireshark die, die Stärke der Pakete kannst du erkennen.
Also das kriegt man wahrscheinlich auf die Reihe.
So, I'm going to be using the I-O-Graph on Wireshark in order to pinpoint the location of the hidden camera.
Ja, so, so hätte ich mir das auch gedacht.
Du guckst einfach, welche Signalstärke die Pakete haben.
Und wenn, wenn die, wenn die hoch ist, bist du nah dran.
Wenn du, wenn du weiter weg bist, ist sie niedriger.
Das ist so in der Richtung hätte ich mir das jetzt auch gedacht.
Nodders, ja.
After we find the device we want to track, we can write a filter using the MAC-Address or as a back-down the camera.
We're going to start with a really low signal strength.
I would presume it's not towards this end.
Es gibt sogar Software fürs Hand, es gibt sogar App für Apps für Android,
um sowas zu machen. Unter IOS geht es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da haben die Apps nicht so viel Zugriff drauf.
Gibt es auch dafür.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, warum man da so ein komisches Detektor-Device braucht.
And if I actually plot this on a logarithmic scale.
Looks like we're getting a jump in signal strength around this area.
Cool, so this general graph pointed the location.
Ja.
Guckt, wo WLAN-Pakete ankommen, die hohe Signalstärke haben.
Richtig krasse Hacker-Shit.
Some phones like this Pixel are able to analyze traffic.
Taking this even further, Wireshark may be able to detect wired Ethernet cameras
that other detectors would have no chance of finding.
Because of course, the wired cameras are not emitting radio signal.
Someone who doesn't get it, but after that you should contact the authorities.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Jetzt.
Jetzt weiß ich auch nicht wirklich.
Weird-Champ-Video.
Keine Ahnung, was mir das sagen sollte jetzt.
Five things Linux does better than Windows.
Okay, sechs Minuten. Bin ich mal gespannt, was die erzählen.
Also es gibt es gibt einige Sachen, die Linux besser als Windows macht.
Es gibt aber auch Sachen, das muss man auch sagen, die Windows besser macht als Linux.
Auch wenn es mich schmerzt an manchen Stellen.
Ich bin nur wirklich kein Fan.
Vom Windows Desktop oder sonst was.
Aber das ist bei weitem nicht so ein Durcheinander wie unter Linux.
Allein schon der Paketmanager.
So viele Tabs offen.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe hier noch mehr Tabs offen.
Es reicht nicht.
Zwei Browser-Fenster mit fast vollen Tabs.
Und so ist das richtig.
Du darfst die Schrift nicht mehr lesen können auf dem Tabs.
Solange du die Schrift noch lesen kannst auf den Tabs, dann ist nicht genug Tabs.
Also allein schon.
Du kannst schon Sachen über einen ordentlichen Package-Manager installieren.
Ist mal meilenweit besser als unter Windows.
Aber gucken wir uns mal an, was sie uns erzählen.
Ich meine, wir können auch einfach.
Nee, können wir nicht.
Probably using Windows as your usual operating system for your PC.
But could there be a good reason for you to consider Linux instead?
Ja, ich benutze Linux täglich.
Kein Ding.
Aber ich benutze Linux und Windows zusammen.
Weil ich so das Beste aus beiden werde.
Weil ich so selten habe und mich nicht rumärgern muss, dass ich das eine
unter dem anderen nicht gescheit machen kann und das andere oder dem einen nicht
gescheit machen kann. Einfach virtualisieren.
Linux unter Windows oder, wenn es einem reicht, WSL verwenden.
Today we're going to go over five good reasons.
Things that Linux does better than Windows.
Starting out with arguably.
Oh, das darfst du.
Das darfst du dem Hardcore-Linux-Fan aber nicht sagen.
Dann wird er dir erst mal sagen.
Ja doch, mit Wine kannst du und du kannst hier und du kannst da und sonst was.
Und es laufen ja sogar Steam und Steam-Spiele laufen.
Im größten Teil.
Aber da muss ich dir recht geben.
Für für Noobs oder Leute, die einfach sagen Hey, ich habe was gelesen.
Ich möchte Spiel XY spielen, weil ich gerade einen Test drüber gelesen habe.
Vergiss es, vergiss es.
Das kannst du keinem zumuten, unter Linux zu spielen.
Deswegen ist die beste Variante einfach Linux haben auf dem zweiten Desktop.
So wie hier und auf dem ersten Desktop Windows fertig
und das verwenden, wo das jeweilige System seine Stärken hat.
Important.
One System Stability.
Now, don't get us wrong.
Ja, has come a long way since the days when Windows me.
Das stimmt wohl. Das stimmt wohl.
Aber ganz im Ernst, die meisten Probleme, die man heutzutage hat,
wenn Windows crasht, sind irgendwelche Hardware Dinger.
Und da hätte Linux auch seine Probleme mit.
Du hast einfach vor allem bei Workstation auf Fullscreen.
Ja, was Blue Screening left and right.
But Linux still maintains its reputation
for being a bit less buggy, at least in terms of the kernel.
While you can run into compatibility issues,
if you try to push a distro beyond what it's designed for, the Linux kernel,
basically the operating system's guts, is known for being stable and reliable,
which is one reason why the vast majority of Web-Servers run on...
Naja, außer man hängt die falschen Parameter an sudo dran.
Wobei, ne, dann stürzt es nicht ab, dann hat man Root-Rechte, aber gut.
Aber das ist ja schon gefixt mittlerweile.
Das sagen immer alle, das ist aber nicht so.
Ich quote das noch mal kurz.
Anyone can look at its code, identify bugs and try out fixes.
Nein.
Es stimmt, dass wohl jeder sich den Code angucken kann.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst.
Niemand, außer vielleicht eine Handvoll
Leute, blicken in den jeweiligen Kernel- Bereichen genug durch, um daran was zu ändern.
Anyone can look at its code, identify bugs.
Nein, das kann nicht jeder.
Es kann jeder an den Code gucken, aber es
kann definitiv nicht jeder Bugs erkennen, geschweige denn fixen.
Garantiert nicht.
Then try out fixes.
And there are lots of people who actively do this.
Und es könnte auch nicht.
Es ist unmöglich.
Du hast du hast vielleicht eine Handvoll
Leute auf der Welt, die in manchen Bereichen im Linux-Könnel durchblicken.
Linux Community is as well as the large
number of companies who use Linux and develop their own Linux distributions.
Although Microsoft is obviously a huge
company, the people examining the Windows code base for bugs are basically just
Microsoft employees, of which there are a finite number.
Windows.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Also generell hast du bei Open Source den Vorteil.
Du hast das Potenzial.
Du hast mehr Potenzial, Sicherheitslücken zu finden, bevor sie relevant werden.
Oder oder na ja, vielleicht auch schneller zu beheben.
Also du kannst.
Es kann sich jeder angucken.
Aber überlegt euch mal, wie viele Bugs auftauchen von.
Shell-Schock bis Hard-Plead bis irgendwelche Debian-Geschichten, Random-Return-5
und solche Sachen.
Die waren teilweise ewig.
Die waren, ich will jetzt nicht sagen Jahrzehnte, aber
fünf, sechs Jahre oder so was teilweise drinne und unentdeckt.
Also da blickt nicht viele Leute durch, geschweige denn.
Gucken überhaupt rein.
Those bugs are often identified and fixed more slowly.
But it isn't just about how many people are looking at the code.
Linux is also built in a more
modular manner than Windows.
This means Linux applications tend to not
mess with the operating systems kernel as much or with other programs.
Windows has caught up to some extent with this.
But Linux still rules the roost when it comes to modularity.
Which brings us to point number two.
Linux is highly customizable.
You can see this in how everything from
servers to Android phones to smart thermostats use versions of Linux.
But what does that mean for you, the home user?
It means that you have real choices.
As to what you want.
You want your user to look and feel like lots of folks think that you need to be
a program or a system admin who's intimately familiar with.
Denn nur nach 15 User kauft sich das Ding,
haut sich die Smartphone App drauf und macht
sich doch keine Gedanken, ob da Linux drunter ist oder nicht.
Man line in order to use Linux.
But there are plenty of Linux.
Persönlich finde es natürlich geil, dass so viele Geräte auf Linux laufen und man
dementsprechend auch an so vielen Geräten dann rumbasteln kann.
Ich bin ja auch Fan von Wir flashen
China-Chinesen-Geräte mit Tasmota, dass die China-Firma runter ist.
Windows CE jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Windows CE ist mal komplett für den Arsch.
Aber ansonsten ist das für die normalen nur nach 15 User.
Dem ist das doch egal.
Distributions such as elementary OS
and Linux Mint geared toward beginners who are migrating over from.
Linux Mint würde ich auch empfehlen.
Tja, watch Videos, da haben wir es schon mal.
Du kannst unter Linux nicht einfach mal
einen Browser öffnen und dann entspannt Videos gucken und dann auch hoffen, dass
dein Rechner nicht am Anschlag ist, was die CPU Leistung angeht bei 4K Videos.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil GPU Decoding
nur wenn die wenn die Planeten in der richtigen Konstellation stehen zur
richtigen Uhrzeit und wenn ich vorher meinen Monitor dreimal links rum gedreht habe,
dann GPU Decoding funktioniert.
You get to choose what your experience is like, as opposed to using just one.
Du empfiehlst Arch, ich auch, ich auch.
Conversion of Windows.
Ich benutze auch Arch, by the way, übrigens.
And many Linux Distributions come with
package managers, which behave like app stores.
So downloading vetted software isn't an issue.
And if you do have the know how and the willingness to learn,
Linux allows you to build or install
so many customizations on top of the kernel.
The exact reason there are so many
Distributions out there that look very different from each other.
And that's really cool.
The third item on our list.
Visualisierst du Linux unter Windows oder umgehen?
Ich virtualisiere Linux unter Windows, weil es einfacher ist,
Linux unter Windows zu virtualisieren als Windows unter Linux.
Ich ich verwende Arch Linux,
wobei ich verwende Manjaro, das geht gar nicht als Arch Linux durch,
habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Security.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Also das, das ist eine Sache, da würde ich sofort zustimmen.
Ja, du hast auch unter, du hast auch unter Linux öfters in letzter Zeit irgendwelche
horrenden, bescheuerten Bugs gehabt.
Wie gesagt, hängst du an Sudo und Parameter hintendran oder nee, nee, nee,
Moment, das war nicht, du hängst ein Parameter an Sudo ran,
du machst ein Sim-Link auf Sudo, so war das doch, gell?
Was da vor zwei Jahren war, da kriegst du gut Rechte.
Ja, aber unterm Strich insgesamt würde ich
sagen, hast du unter Linux deutlich, deutlich weniger solcher Probleme.
So Geschichten wie ein Javascript Interpreter im Windows Defender mit
Hutrechten, sowas hast halt unter Linux nicht.
Wann macht es denn Sinn, eher Windows zu
verwenden außer Gaming, Gaming oder aber du möchtest Software verwenden, die
halt unter Linux nicht funktioniert?
Ja, sei es jetzt beispielsweise bei mir
zum Beispiel Sony Vegas tut nicht unter Linux gescheit.
Die Sachen, die ich für Thumbnails zum
erstellen benutze, funktioniert unter Linux nicht gescheit.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
nachdenken würde, bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen, dann kannst vergessen.
Oder oder auch wenn du zum Beispiel spezielle Hardware hast.
Ja, sagen wir jetzt mal, du hast irgendein
Etikettendrucker oder so, wo es dann nur Windows, wobei da mittlerweile auch einiges.
Wie vieles zumindest unter Linux funktioniert, kannst vergessen.
Oder du brauchst irgendwelche Hardware Dongle, dass deine Software startet.
Oder du hast irgendwelches olle Business Zeug, was du brauchst, dass deine Firma
läuft. Es gibt halt genug Sachen, die funktionieren nicht richtig unter Linux
und die werden es wahrscheinlich auch nicht gescheit.
Benutzt du aber auf der Arbeit Outlook im Browser?
Ja.
Mach ich echt zwei Prozent.
So viel haben wir mittlerweile.
Ja, dann wird es ja mal Zeit.
Dann ist doch 2022 das Jahr des Linux des Tops, oder was?
Was meint ihr?
Five reasons to try Windows.
Although Linux is by far the most popular
OS on the servers, connect to all the time to use the Internet.
Das stimmt. Hackers definitely try hard to breach
these systems malware target toward desktop Linux Distros is much rarer.
Gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Linux also doesn't normally give users as much
access to low level system files and functions as Windows does,
meaning any malware that does find its way into your system tends to be easier
to isolate and remove.
We will go on to item number three right
after we thank Zoho CRM for sponsoring this video.
Zoho CRM is a 360° solution for managing to customize your experience so that you
can spot critical information at a
falling cost. Get a link in the video description.
Speaking of removing junk, let's talk about
this item Privacy.
Gibt es irgendeinen Nachteil bei Chromium?
Je nachdem, welche Edition du verwendest, hast du halt manche Sachen nicht drinne.
Du hast zum Beispiel bei manchen kein Chromecast drinne
oder
keine gescheite Hardware Beschleunigung bei WebGL und solche Geschichten.
Muss gucken, muss genau gucken, welches Chromium Bild du verwendest.
Aber ansonsten hast du keine wirklichen Nachteile.
That Microsoft is a big fan
of tracking your online activity in order to do everything from improving its AIs to
serving you what it thinks are relevant ads.
And it's quite difficult.
Das ist tatsächlich eines der riesen
Dinger und was ich auch immer noch toll finde.
Du musst dir keine Gedanken machen.
Du brauchst keine Account.
Du hast keinen Account Zwang.
Ja, lege jetzt ein Microsoft Account an.
Lege jetzt hier, lege jenes an, hinterlege das hier und sonst was.
Du hast keine Werbung.
Du hast keine Ads.
Du hast keine
Account Zwang.
Du hast nichts, was dich nervt.
Du kannst dir sicher sein, es schickt
standardmäßig zumindest nichts, keine Software was heim.
Wenn, dann hast du dich selbst installiert.
Das ist tatsächlich eines der großen Vorteile auch für mich.
Ja, also man kann sicherlich deutlich beruhigter Linux verwenden als Windows.
Und wenn ich mal auf irgendwelche Webseiten muss, die so ein bisschen shady sind, wo ich
nicht genau weiß, ob sie nicht versuchen, irgendwelche Viren unterzuschieben,
vor allem an Linux Browser auf draufgehen, kann dir eigentlich nichts passieren.
Ubuntu Funk meines Wissens.
Ja, Ubuntu, das habe ich schon abgeschrieben.
Ubuntu hatte doch auch mal diese Amazon Werbung im Start Menü.
Upon Turn Off Tracking Windows Mix Dig down and find multiple settings.
Und du kannst nicht alles abschalten.
If you do this, there are some kinds of data that we will just keep saying to Microsoft.
Ja, regardless.
But because Linux is open source, there's not a monolithic company behind it,
hoping to make tons of money off of every Linux user.
And there's no provision for any kind of tracking by default.
While there are some Linux distributions
that do engage in some limited forms of tracking like Ubuntu, it's typically easier.
Ubuntu, wir wissen doch alle, dass das
heißt, wenn man das richtig ausspricht.
To opt out or just find a different distribution that doesn't send any data.
Wird Manjaro eigentlich auch von einem Unternehmen maintained?
Nee, das ist von irgendeinem, ich glaube,
das sogar von irgendeinem Deutschen ist der Ober-Manjaro-Entwickler, irgendein Deutscher.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der gesponsert wird full time für die Arbeit.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
This is a good segue into our fifth and final point.
Linux is a heck of a lot better at keeping your money in your own pocket.
Obviously, you can install and use Windows for free.
As long as you don't mind that annoying
watermark and not being able to pick your own desktop wallpaper.
But Microsoft still uses Windows to get
you to spend money on its services, such as Microsoft 365,
OneDrive and apps from the Microsoft Store, in which Microsoft gets a cut of the money.
Most Linux users, however, won't be tempted to spend much, if anything,
to get the most out of their system.
Das ist schon richtig, aber.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Qualität vieler Open Source
Alternativen, es ist auch egal, ob man die unter Windows oder Linux verwendet,
nicht an bezahlte Anwendungen rankommt.
Es gibt genug Software, die ist frei und kostenlos und die ist besser
als irgendwelchen, irgendwelchen Krempel, den du kaufst.
Aber es gibt genauso gut Sachen.
Da findest du einfach nichts Gescheites.
Ich glaube, Video Editor ist.
Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da was Gescheites gibt, was an sowas wie Vegas
oder Premiere rankommt.
Aber spätestens wenn man anfängt mit Gimp versus es muss ja nicht mal Photoshop sein.
Es reicht ja, es reicht ja schon, wenn man
hier mal die die Billigdinger, die ich verwende, nimmt.
Das kannst du, das kannst du knicken.
Blender ist Poggers.
Ja, ich sage ja, es gibt genug Open Source
Zeug, was wirklich geil und wirklich nice ist.
Aber es gibt halt auch umgedreht Dinger.
Das ist halt.
Da merkst du schon, dass es halt ein Projekt ist, wo ein Typ am Wochenende
ab und zu mal ein bisschen was dran bastelt.
Bei Blender ist das was anderes.
Bei Blender stehen ja auch hunderte Leute.
Und Contributors und alles mögliche dahinter.
Hey, companies like Red Hat for Linux support and training.
The average home user using an approachable Linux distribution won't have
a large company trying to get them to buy more stuff and most of the programs you
need to accomplish your goals are available for free.
So those are our top five.
But we know there are plenty of Linux fans jumping.
Jetzt wollen sie ein bisschen kommen.
Kommens beten, dass das für den Algorithmus besser ist.
Ja, so was. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding.
Wenn du zum Beispiel was suchst.
Ja, genau so was zum Beispiel.
Oder auch wenn du was suchst, wo du
gescheit 500 3D Drucker Modelle machen kannst.
So was wie Fusion 360 und so was.
Das gibt es auch zum größten Teil nur Paid ist halt in manchen Bereichen ist super.
Und lässt nichts zu wünschen übrig.
In anderen Bereichen gibt es halt nicht viel.
Ich habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht.
Ich kann mir bloß nicht vorstellen, dass das da glaube ich dir das einfach mal.
Also gerade bei denen hier.
Im Leben nicht.
Als Alternative zu Vegas oder Premiere.
Und ist das nicht irgendeine Effekt Geschichte?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ja gut, das heißt ja nichts, dass das.
Ja, dann ist dann ist anscheinend wirklich.
Na, ich meine nur, weil im professionellen Umfeld irgendwas verwendet wird.
Es ist immer noch kein Ersatz für den
15 Typ, der daheim ein Thumbnail oder ein Video für YouTube machen will.
Ja, ist gut. Ist gut, dass es was gibt.
Gut, dass es was gibt.
Aber im Bild Bearbeitung Bereich ist halt immer noch immer noch mau und ich denke auch
gerade was Audio Bearbeitung angeht, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie es da aussieht.
Ja, wenn es nicht free ist, dann sind wir ja beim sind wir beim Thema, dass man eben
manche Software einfach nichts Gutes bekommt, was aus aus Open Source Ecke.
Ja, Audacity kann es ja nicht wirklich als Audio Bearbeitung durchgehen lassen.
Audacity verwende ich auch, um auf Aufnahme zu drücken, mein Kram einzusprechen und fertig.
Aber das kann es ja nicht mit.
Ja, normal mit irgendeiner Audio Workstation oder so vergleichen.
Ja, das kann möglich, möglich.
Ja, aber das kannst du trotzdem nicht mit irgendwelchen.
Ich wie gesagt, ich bin im Audio Bereich nicht nicht so an.
Kämme nicht so aus.
Aber wenn ich mir angucke, was ich da
beispielsweise schon in Videos gesehen habe von Leute, die auf ihrem in dem Fall war
es ein Mac auf ihrem Mac ihre ihre Digital Audio Workstation aufhaben.
Da kannst du nicht mit Audis Audacity dagegen anscheißen.
Kennst du die Mettlab aus?
Nö, es ist gut, dass es immer mehr gibt, aber in manchen Bereichen kommst du nicht drumherum.
Warum löscht du eigentlich immer die 1 aus dem Link?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1.
Da habe ich das versucht, erklärt zu erklären.
Genau.
Das ist kein gescheite das oder so.
Was heißt kein Gescheit?
Das ist diesen ganzen Office Krempel unter Linux.
Ich weiß, dass es LibreOffice gibt ja unter Linux nicht gibt.
Juckt mich persönlich gar nicht,
weil ich verwende keine Office.
Programme für nix.
Ja, das ist, warum ich die 1 kopiere.
Stimmt ja tatsächlich Office 365.
Wo sie das Office 365 React basiert ist.
Ja, was krippt?
Stell's Kram.
Ja, stimmt. Office 365 kannst du verwenden.
PowerPoint im Browser ist gruselig.
Du wirst lachen.
Meine letzten Präsentationen der letzten
Jahre habe ich alle über PowerPoint im Browser gemacht.
Das hat nämlich einen großen Vorteil.
Man kann mit Leuten zusammen editieren.
Man sieht dann, was der andere editiert.
Wenn es nach mir geht, wenn es nach mir geht,
würde ich dafür auch kein PowerPoint verwenden.
Aber bei mir in der Firma ist das so.
Die stehen da unglaublich drauf.
Wenn man diese Corporate Vorlage verwendet
und wenn man nicht die Corporate Vorlage verwendet, wirst du gleich Chef angeguckt.
Normalerweise wisst ihr, was ich normalerweise machen würde?
Ich würde fünf Markdown Seiten machen, PDF daraus exportieren und fertig.
Ja, ja, ja gut, bringt ja nix.
PowerPoint selbst läuft ja unter Linux nicht.
Bleibt dir nur Office 365.
Präsentations Livestream.
Nee, das ist ein bisschen zu viel Firmeninternes Zeug, oder?
Ja, genug Unverwundbarkeits-Sound.
Wort darüber meine Katze, da muss ich aber keine Präsentation zu machen.
Okay, Leute.
Schon spät.
Was ist jetzt richtig Bett getimed?
22 Uhr gleich.
So sieht es aus.
Muss ich mal überlegen. Ja.
Die Katze, die rennt hier im Flur rum.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten Stream.
C.U. Macht's gut. Kann ich jemand hausten?
Zeigt mal kurz irgendjemand.
Aber im Lost geht es ab hier 4,1 k Zuschauer.
Ah, ich glaube, die spielen Dings hier.
Rast, Rast-Tournamenter.
Ähm, irgendein kleinerer?
Nö.
Alles klar, bis denn.
C.U.